Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
In the last video,
we ended with the end of the civil war.
The period following the civil war is
often called the reconstruction era,
referring as you might expect to the
reconstruction of the union following it's
divide while the south was
being reintegrated into
the nation and rebuilt the
north and the West would take off and
industry commerce and technological
development, transcontinental
railroads enabled quicker passage,
the western parts of the nation.
It once took six months to
reach California from New York.
Now it took only a week as settlers
moved into the west. However,
they encroached further on native
American territory leading to considerable
amounts of conflict with them,
which would last until the 1890s many
natives who were not killed and resistance
replaced on reservations and some
attempts to integrate them were made.
Many people will be employed as well and
the industries that would rule the east
of the nation and turn the United States
into the greatest industrial power in
the world.
This age would be the rise of corporations
in America and many at the time felt
that corporations were interfering
with the nation's down to Earth,
democratic nature.
What was seen as corruption on the part
of the corporations would lead to labor
organizations and unions such as in
Knights of labor in 1869 strikes and
protests would grow more frequent and
such movements would help characterize the
age as well as factories, corporations
and centers of industry, schools,
hospitals,
museums,
and centers of art and culture in such
things would pop up across the nation.
Science would also prosper here with
scientists such as Nikola Tesla,
Alexander Graham Bell and Thomas Edison
Active Alaska will be purchased in 1867
in a purchase remarked as Seward's folly,
famous American author,
Mark Twain would coined a term for
the 1870s to the early 20th century.
The gilded age as a typical name
representing social upheaval with a silver
lining.
Both the industries in the east and
expansion westward would be undertaking my
huge numbers of immigrants
pouring into the country.
According to the US Census Bureau,
from the end of the civil war
to the start of World War,
one 28 million immigrants would pour
into the nation, almost all from Europe,
some from British Canada, Quebec,
and some from Asia as well.
Though Asians were typically more
unwelcomed than other European groups.
In 1880 the population of
the u s had 50 million.
As Jim crow laws began reversing
their rights of blacks in the south.
The women's suffrage movement would
rise up in this era. During this time,
American foreign policy would
change as well. Prior to this,
the United States have been
somewhat isolationists.
We see several examples of
what we would call imperialism.
The obvious example is the decades
of conquest against native Americans,
but also of course the Mexican American
war and the Monroe doctrine and things
of that nature, but now
with the continent, very
much under American control,
American politicians,
businessmen and military leaders turn
their sights on the international theater.
It's often debated whether
or not America had an empire,
mostly because it did an act exactly
similarly to the European empires across
the world, mostly because it had plenty
of opportunity in his home region.
But while the word empire is more
contested prior to these decades,
if it is applicable at all, which I
encourage you to decide for yourself,
it very likely begins here
with a Spanish American war.
During the 1870s up through the 1890s
nearby Cuba had been pushing for
independence in an age where an American
Trey expand that across the world.
American businessmen pushing to expand
their markets into the region and fueled
newspapers,
highlighting and exaggerating Spanish
atrocities on the island against the
rebels.
In 1898 when an American ship in Havana
harbor called the USS Maine exploded,
the Spanish army was immediately
blamed in newspapers,
blew up the issue across a nation,
though the Spanish were
likely not responsible, this
would force the government,
which was somewhat unwilling
into the Spanish American war.
During this war which
lasted only three months,
Cuba was liberated and the Philippines,
Puerto Rico and Guam were annexed.
The conflict would later break out
between the U S and Philippines and it'll
become independent in 1946 also in 1898
Hawaii would be annexed following the
overthrowing of the Hawaiian Queen,
the progressive era named
after the progressive movement,
which focused on tackling social labor
and political inequalities arose in the
1890s journalists who
focused on the corruption and
everything from the politics
of the day to the unsanitary
conditions of the meatpacking industry.
We're referred to as
muckrakers labor reforms,
increases in sanitation
and social movements would
intensify in a Sarah Spanish
American war veteran Theodore Roosevelt,
who had become presidents after the
assassination of William Mckinley became
president in 1901 and would be a leading
progressive president doing things such
as establishing the FDA and
expanding national parks.
He would continue an imperialist
foreign policy. However,
expanding the power of American military,
focusing on foreign threats and laying
the foundations for the Panama Canal to
be built in 19 no wait,
the Ford model t would be introduced
on the market regarded as the first
affordable car. It would
revolutionize American transportation.
In 1912 Arizona will become a state
becoming a final state and the continuous
United States,
the main continent had now been
successfully won in 1914 rising political
conflict in Europe would eventually
explode into the first world war.
The United States,
while very much affected by the conflict
chose at first to stay out of European
affairs.
However much the government and populous
favor of the allied side public opinion
began to shift increasingly toward war.
When German submarines fired on and
sank the Lusitania carrying American
civilian passengers, the German stated
that they would not repeat the incident,
though this eventually proved to not be
true and the Germans fired on any ships
approaching Britain. Later, a
message from the German government,
the Mexican government known as the
Zimmerman telegram and forming the Mexican
government, that if they were to
declare war on the United States,
they will be supported by the Germans
and their reconquest of lands lost during
the war was discovered by the United
States and this mixed with unofficial
German hostility would lead to
American entry into the war.
In April of 1917 under president Woodrow
Wilson and truce begin arriving in 1918
the United States military
was still rather small and
ill equipped as it had not
been involved in a major
war since the civil war.
American industry now turn toward weaponry
and the draft was started while the
war was in its final parts of fresh
American troops in sudden surplus of
supplies and efforts are placed to
withdrawing Russians and help secure the
eventual allied victory.
A year later on November 11th,
1918 the central powers
surrendered to the allied forces.
The war would officially be ended
with a treaty of Versailles where the
victorious nations of Britain,
France,
and the United States along with many
other nations negotiated the terms of the
treaty at the palace of Versailles
in France, Germany. However,
it was not included in the negotiations
and would essentially be forced to
accept the terms, namely land loss,
reduction of their military power,
demands of operations, and
assuming responsibility for
the outbreak of the war.
Though the war's beginning have
blamed on all sides of Europe.
Germany was outrage,
but the United States was also a post and
most of these conditions and refuse to
sign the treaty.
Wilson's main intentions were to repair
the damage and avoid another war,
namely with things like the
formation of a League of nations,
but Congress would not approve of the
treaty or the entry into the League of
nations, which would create tension
for years to come during world war one,
feminism in the United States and
become active again. Generally,
it hadn't felt that if only men could
participate in war is only mentioned vote.
However,
female efforts at home and overseas a
returned many of these conceptions and in
1919 the 19th amendment was passed,
giving women the right to
vote following the war.
The United States would return to what
some would call it unilateralism and
others.
As I've said,
isolationism basically
focusing on domestic affairs
and keeping a distance from
foreign conflicts and alliances and such.
The economy would grow
from industry and trade,
which is why the 1920s are often called
the roaring twenties some of this
business was illegal. However, as shortly
before the 18th amendment was passed,
which banned the sale and transportation
of alcohol inspired by groups of
Lutheran and seeking to edit things
like alcoholism, family violence,
and other places, society that they felt
alcohol created. Prohibition was gritty,
protested and increased organized
crime throughout the nation.
While decreasing tax revenue,
it would not be repealed until 1933
the error also saw a number of social,
cultural and technological reforms.
Jazz music became popular.
Social Roles, namely those of women
began to change. Automobiles, aviation,
the first movies, telephones, radio,
the modern organization of sports.
The media's focus on
unimportant celebrities,
many of these kinds of things which
are very much still a part of American
culture and in fact the western culture
have their origins in this time period.
The roaring twenties however,
would not last at the end of the decade.
On October 29th,
1929 the stock market crashed.
This along with a number of other economic
factors would mark the beginning of
what is called the Great Depression.
An era of worldwide increases
in unemployment and poverty
and decreases in GDP
and trade.
In the United States,
industrial production
fell 46% wholesale prices,
32% foreign trade is 70% and unemployment
increased 607% or from about 3% of the
population before the depression to 25%
of the population. At the end of it,
President Herbert Hoover attempted to
reinvigorate the American economy with
government influence and the economy,
notably the construction
of public buildings,
the most famous of which
is the Hoover dam. However,
he would fail and much of his efforts,
but in 1932 president Franklin d Roosevelt
was elected after promising Americans
a new deal is early administration is
important and that it marked much of the
beginning of the modern American
government's influence in society as he
attempted to turn the
great depression around.
Through creating a number
of new government agencies
is subsidizing farmers,
saving the banks from collapse,
lowering government salaries,
switching off from the gold standard
and expanding many labor programs across
the country.
He would indeed be instrumental and
revitalizing much of the country and his
fireside chats. Regular radio
broadcast the liver to the public.
He would share many of his
ideas and plans for the country.
In the late 1930s however,
Roosevelt took more of a role in
foreign policy as was feared by many.
The recited treaty had, for all intents
and purposes, failed and an anger.
Germany was rising under the
leadership of Adolph Hitler.
War once again seems
eminent on the continent.
It did indeed come when Germany invaded
Poland in 1939 and France and Britain
declared war when France was beaten
by Germany much more quickly than was
expected.
Concern grew in the United States have a
serious conflict and the government did
lose much of its intention to
remain isolated from the conflict.
The United States did not enter the war,
but it did unofficially take a side
with the allied nations of Britain,
the Soviet Union, the French Resistance in
China against Germany, Japan, and Italy.
By setting them supplies and arms.
In 1941 Japan was stale
mating with the Chinese,
but was looking to expand
into other regions as well,
most notably Southeast Asia.
However,
Southeast Asia had been
colonized predominantly by
the British and the United
States. Recall, of course,
that the Philippines,
we're essentially an American colony
annex. Following the Spanish American war,
the Japanese knew that it could not match
the British and American naval support,
but it nevertheless felt a
pressure to expand into their lens.
So a decided instead to attempt to wipe
out the allied naval bases in the region
before war,
which they saw as inevitable
began on December 7th,
1941 date, which President
Roosevelt said with live in infamy,
the Japanese attack,
the American naval base at Pearl Harbor.
The United States now had entered into
a war against Japan and subsequently
Hitler declared war on the US.
While Roosevelt had walked to join the
war in some manner he now has from the
American people, which followed from the
attack and the u s began to mobilize.
The attack on Pearl Harbor was much
less of a victory than was intended,
but the Japanese began
successfully assaulting much
of Asia taking American and
British territory rapidly extending all
the way up to the borders of British
India and Australia.
Even support on the allied side now
increased considerably with the direct
American intervention in the war.
The U s would invade North Africa along
with the British in June of 1942 the US
would win the battle of midway in
the Pacific against Japan dealing a
devastating blows their navy.
In September of that year,
the u s would engage the
Japanese at Guadalcanal and
would win an early 1943 the
war was beginning to turn around in 1943
in Europe as well as the Soviet Union
was beginning to repel German advances.
Italians and Germans surrendered in North
Africa in May and the allies invaded
mainland Italy in September.
The others came to a standstill even
though many Italians were not sympathetic
to the allies.
The allies had planned for an alternative
routes into Europe through northern
France.
The invasion,
which was the largest
seaborne invasion in history,
came on June 6th, 1944 often
referred to as d day and Normandy,
France.
Five key beaches were selected by the
allies to obtain in the effort nickname
that Utah and Omaha,
which the Americans we focus
on the British at Golden
Sword and the Canadians at
Juno, the ranks we bolstered by soldiers
from many other countries as well,
including the French Resistance,
Australians checks, Norwegians, Poles,
and dames leading the Americans here
was General Dwight d Eisenhower.
The Germans were rather unprepared for
this assault as they were expecting it to
come on. Kallai around 10,000
people would die in these battles,
but they were successful allied victory
as a now how to foot hold on the
continent and the east general Douglas
Macarthur pushed and closer toward
mainland Japan throughout the rest of
1944 and into 1945 the allies pushed and
had Germany, Britain, America, Canada,
and their allies from the west with
the Soviet Union from the east with the
Soviets and circling
Berlin Germany's capital.
Hitler committed suicide on April 30th,
1945 and his successor made
peace despite Hitler's wishes.
It was made official on May 7th,
1945 now known as the e or
a victory in Europe Day.
The European theater had been one,
but the eastern theater spearheaded
primarily by the United States was still
active. The Japanese we're
losing, but we're still
fiercely resisting. The allies.
Fear to land invasion of Japan would
be brutal, costly, and drawn up,
possibly lasting for years.
However,
the United States had
another plan that same year.
The first successful atomic bomb test
had been had taken place in New Mexico.
Now the Americans intended
to use it on Japan.
The decision fell under the
presidency of Harry s Truman,
as Roosevelt had died on April 12th of
that year while serving his fourth term,
it was approved and the
cities of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki were bombed on August
6th and ninth in 1945 the
month the Japanese surrendered
and the war had come to
a close. The war had claimed the
lives of around 60 million people,
perhaps even up to 80 million
if you include the seeds
and famines caused by the
war. Many were soldiers, many
were civilian casualties.
Some civilians around 11 million or
so were specific targets. As a Nazi.
He's intended to rid Germany of groups.
They considered undesirable or
troublesome through genocide,
known as a holocaust, most literally
6 million Jews, but also homosexuals,
the mentally handicapped Gypsies,
communists and sterilize
other groups like blacks.
World War II fundamentally
change the United States.
It had pulled the nation out of the
Great Depression with a large increase in
GDP and ended unemployment and had
modernize the American military,
but many changes were unprecedented
in all of American history.
The United States how to merge to replace
the Europeans as a world power and
that had come out of the isolation
and general self sufficiency,
which which the founding fathers had
intended for the nation and jumped into
being active in the entire world theater
a change which lasts to this day.
Furthermore, though the US had lost
around 400,000 soldiers in the war,
the mainland was essentially
unraveled by conflict.
Unlike much of Europe and Asia
allowing for more unimpeded growth,
United States was not the only world
power to emerge from the fight. However,
the Soviet Union though
it had faced horrifying
destruction and his homeland and
major losses.
Pet also merged as a dominant world
power and the strain between the two was
evident even before the war was over.
The two sides,
the US letting one and the USSR,
the other forum to not merely at a
geopolitical tensions and interests,
but economic and ideological
tensions as well.
And the earlier parts of the 20th century,
Russia had been overthrown
by communist revolution.
The United States had opposed this
revolution from beginning and much of the
capitalist west were hostile toward it.
Up to this time period.
The USSR had been somewhat isolationist
up to this point as well though not as
much.
However,
it now saw an opportunity to spread
its ideology across the globe as well.
The newly formed United Nations was
created with an intent to try to prevent a
certain what war which with the Soviet
and American scoring up did not seem like
such an impossibility.
And the era in which such a devastating
conflict loom that's a threat is known
as the Cold War era. Both sides
claim to be fighting for freedom,
liberation and overall
good and battles to come.
But for now they were
busy dividing Europe.
Debate emerged over how to divide posts.
Nazi Europe.
The Soviets were keen on maintaining the
lands which they had occupied following
the war.
While the western side was intent on
keeping communism from spreading and war
torn nations work again, a foothold,
a policy known as containment.
This division has split Germany between
East and West as well as the capital of
Berlin itself. The United States
eventually adopted the Marshall Plan,
which serves to provide resources
and funds to fight against communists
takeovers and help reconstruct
Europe and Japan at home as well.
There was concern of communist takeover
and anticommunist propaganda became
increased as a red scare
took root in a nation.
In 1949 the two sides became more clearly
differentiated when and respond to the
Warsaw Pact created by the Soviet Union.
The U s helps found NATO or the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization between these
two nations exist a metaphorical wall
or as Winston Churchill described it in
iron curtain. As the Soviets tested their
first nuclear weapon that same year,
it became clearer that any conflict that
would emerge directly between the two
nations would be even more to Shuck Div.
In the Second World War,
possibly even as scientists and military
experts came to conclude a threat to
the human species itself.
The situation of the world was changing.
The old European empires of
Britain, France, Germany,
Portugal, Spain, et cetera.
We're now ending as new nations rose
up and revolutions or grunted freedoms
peacefully.
The United States and Soviet Union both
attempted to influence these new nations
and wind them to their side and
defining aspect of the Cold War.
In the 1950s many conflicts
would emerge from the cold war.
The Korean War was one of the first
following World War II who Korea was
liberated from Japan,
but also to vita between the USSR and
the US and emerged as to separate nations
of north and South Korea.
Neither side was indeed
content on remaining separate
nations and eventually war
broke out between them.
In 1950 the north was supported by the
USSR and eventually more directly by the
newly formed Communist.
People's Republic of China.
The South was supported by the United
Nations and send soldiers into Korea on
South Korea's behalf consisting
primarily of American soldiers.
However, when the Chinese
entered the war on Korea side,
the two sides eventually
reached a stalemate and
President Eisenhower was eager
to make peace, which they did in 1953
vote. A vision remains to this day.
In 1960 John F.
Kennedy was elected as president.
In 1961 the CIA attempted to overthrow
the Cuban dictator, Fidel Castro,
using Cuban exiles in what is
known as the Bay of Pigs invasion.
But Castro likely knew the invasion was
coming and defeated us backed forces and
solidify the country
against the western powers.
Cuba's relations with the Soviet
Union would continue to grow,
which worried many Americans as Cuba
is a mere 90 miles from the coast of
Florida.
The following year,
the Soviets intended to send
nuclear missiles to Cuba,
but President Kennedy and Soviet leader,
Nikita Khrushchev agreed to remove
nuclear missiles from Cuban Turkey,
avoiding an escalation to what could
become a third world war known as a Cuban
missile crisis. In 1957 a new
conflict emerged from the cold war,
though not one of arms and soldiers,
but of technology and science.
The space race,
the space race was a competition to
explore space which was rooted and the
potential that technology would extend
conflict into outer space and that the
first nation to get a foothold in this
new theater would have an advantage in
near succumb.
The Soviet Union would put the first
satellite in this space in 1957 known as
Sputnik and in 1961 would put the first
human in his space, Uri Gaga Green.
However,
in 1969 in the United States with land,
the first person on the moon and in fact
a whole nother world, Neil Armstrong,
however,
the 1967 space treaty prohibited land
claims or the establishment of military
bases on the moon or
other celestial bodies.
Once the solar system was designated
for scientific study alone,
the US and Russia began to cool their
efforts into space and no nation ever did
anything of equivalent magnitude in space.
Again,
in 1964 following the
Gulf of Tonkin incident,
two incidents in which was claimed
that Vietnamese ships had fired.
I'm the U S has Maddix,
although there is uncertain evidence that
this actually happened. The specialty,
the second attack though
possibly the first as well,
the United States began taking a more
direct role in another war raging from the
aftermath of European decolonization.
Civil war had been raging there since
at least 1955 following liberation from
France in Vietnam,
socialists back northerners were engaged
in conflict against the NATO back south.
The war waged on into the 70s and may
protest against if utility and lack of
necessity for the war
erupted in the United States,
which put pressure on the government
to limit participation in it.
Though it was considered vital by the
government and much of the population to
stop the spread of communism in Southeast
Asia and the u s pressed hard dropping
more bombs in Vietnam then were used
in all of World War II and utilizing
chemical weapons such as agent orange.
During this time,
the public was protesting many other
things besides increased American military
intervention across the world.
Many social movements,
particularly those concern the
rights of African Americans,
women and other minorities sprang up
and notable figure from this time period
was Dr. Martin Luther King Jr who sought
to end institutionalized racism against
African Americans and achieve
complete equal status.
This was essentially achieved
by 1968 though he was
assassinated later that year,
legal racial equality had been achieved,
but throughout the 70s many Americans
felt that traditional values were under
attack by more extreme social movements
and there was a call for them to return
on a conservative leadership leading
to the election of Richard Nixon.
Though he would eventually
resigned following the
Watergate scandal in 1979 the
United States withdrew from Vietnam.
Is North Vietnamese successfully
conquered the rest of the country.
This war was the first in history which
the United States it clearly lost.
Recall of course that wars like Korea
or more distantly the war of 1812 are
considered still mates and from
some perspectives, victories.
Those who had supported the war were
disappointed with the outcome Lois would
oppose that were angered by what they
saw as a disingenuous nature of the
government and pursuing it. The larger
cold war still continued, however,
throughout the 70s but though the east
and west pursued more peaceful relations,
economic conditions in the United States,
worse than in the 70s in many companies
even moved outside of the nation.
Cities like Detroit, Chicago, Cleveland,
and New York in particular were
hit by an economic downfall.
In 1980 peaceful relations with the
Soviet Union began to sour again as a
Soviets invaded Afghanistan
to install a communist regime.
There there had already been turmoil in
the Middle East on both sides and the
region, whether it's great
wealth of oil became important.
Both the Soviet Union
and the United States.
President Carter announced the Soviet
Union for their invasion and led many
countries to boycott the 1980 Moscow
Olympics in 1980 president Ronald Reagan
was elected unifying may,
branches of conservative thought.
He believed in both
limited federal government,
but also was vigorously active
in pursuing the Cold War.
He increased military
spending dramatically and
attempted to give the US the
capability to shoot down Soviet missiles
in space. Though this endeavor failed,
he would also engage in conflicts in
Lebanon, Grenada, Libya, El Salvador,
Guatemala, and also supported with
how to Dean rebels in Afghanistan.
Though this organization would
later turn into the al Qaeda,
more specifically with the Soviets, how
were things were beginning to look bleak?
The Soviet Union was falling behind
technologically and economically,
and that was becoming more evident to
the rest of the world. Mikhail Gorbachev,
the Soviet Union's leader at the time
attempted to save communism in the USSR by
ending the arms race with the u s and by
releasing and script on Eastern Europe.
But this would fail.
And on Christmas Day,
1991 the Soviet Union would fall
apart in communism with it and Russia,
the Cold War had ended. The United
States emerged from the Cold War,
as for all intents and purposes and
unchallenged superpower and continue to
intervene in foreign complex.
Some saw this as American imperialism
and the betrayal of nation's founding
principles, others as an obligation
to police the world as it is called,
following nearly a century of horrific
warfare and the potential for even worse
warfare. Either way, they
will continue to do so.
As George H w Bush intervened in Kuwait
against Iraq, remembered as a Gulf war,
which was a decisive victory.
This continued intervention and world
affairs along with inventions like the
Internet and faster means
of transportation and
communication and things of that
nature have led to terms like
globalization popping up in politics,
which can be ambiguous
and have many meanings,
but refers generally to a world which
is becoming increasingly connected.
A world in which the United States
is playing a leading role as day.
Throughout the 90s and into the modern
day terrorism began increasing in the
United States and in fact,
much of the world,
the great majority of these terrorists
being from Islamic radical groups,
the most significant incident and American
history of such a terrorist attack is
referred to as nine 11 and attack on the
World Trade Center on September 11th,
2001 as well as the Pentagon and the
failed attack on Washington d c these
attacks would mark the beginning of
increased conflict in the Middle East in
Iraq and Afghanistan.
The occurrences of wish we had dealt
with through the presidency of America's
first black President Barack Obama,
into our modern day with Donald J.
Trump serving as our 45th
we still continue to face
many of the economic strains
I began and the two
thousands or even further,
as well as a continuation
of social movements to have
roots in the nation's very
foundation. And thus we have reached
our own era. And this documentary.
Needless to say,
the United States of 1776 and the 2018
are almost completely different worlds in
terms of government and
political structure and
culture and societal structure
changes obviously to be expected as
the events we have discussed in this
documentary reshaped
the nation year by year.
But in deciding the future
of the United States,
we must study the history and the side,
which changes are for the
good and which were mistakes.
But that is something I leave
to you to decide for yourself.
The United States is a new nation,
but it may indeed have many years to come.
And its future as a democratic nation
depends upon the decisions of the various
groups of peoples who inhabited most
of which, what is done with land.
The cell considered the land
of opportunity to support
the creation and more
videos like these.
A link to our patriarch.
We have found in the description below.
For more videos like this and
videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.